Is the door to Iron Man totally closed
because I don't believe it is. oh? You guys
can go through time now you can go
there was you know, you already
opened up that door. Let me ask you the
question if I pick the jersey back up
and put it on wouldn't you feel a little
bit like oh no crap no oh
Here's what, here's what I think. They
go through a few semi lackluster
Avengers movies without you.
You ready for this? I'm ready. Here's the
scene there's a moment where the world's
fate is at stake and they've realized
they need a super genius and then they
figure out how to restart that time
machine. Great. Come on man. Is that your?
the audience sees you when you step out of
that thing? Is this your, and can we you
want a little arc on it too? Because if
this is your idea then you got to show
up for it too. I'll do it. I'll show up.
What do I have to do? I don't know? I'll do
whatever I have to do? We all have to do
whatever Kevin Feige says. I'll hold that thing.
I'll hold the clap thing. Do they stil have that?
They do, it's digital.
I'll hold that digital thing.
I'll do it! But the way
people would freak out if you came back
mm-hmm come on
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my new
Iron Man Avengers 5 video you probably
saw the news because Robert Downey jr.
has been doing all this press for his
new non Marvel movie people have been
asking him about coming back as Iron Man
this just happens to be one of the more
compelling pitches that he's heard so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch
of Easter eggs in here inadvertently Joe
Rogan does reference some very specific
Avengers stories maybe without realizing
it so if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos we're doing a new infinity saga
box that giveaway for all the blu-rays
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about how to bring Iron Man back without
completely undermining his sacrifice
because that's the big question and they
kind of address it during this Joe Rogan
clip so how do you bring him back
without completely undermining that
great moment the Avengers end game
ending when he snaps vanos away Robert
Downey jr. also talks a little bit about
some cool moments hanging out with the
other Avengers actors after all this
happened in real life when they're not
busy filming stuff because a lot of them
don't see each other that often in real
life we'll just bring this down top 5
style starting with number 5 so Joe
Rogan's first big go-to for
justifying that he come back is actually
from a more practical standpoint Marvel
tries a new Avengers movie without
including him or our big team up movie
and it performs terribly at the box
office by comparison really good example
that is Avengers endgame it is the
highest-earning movie in the history of
movies now that was that whole big run
why they re-released it in theaters just
so they could past James Cameron's first
Avatar movie just so they could cross
the finish line and say we have the
highest-grossing movie of all time
now James Cameron is totally going to come
back with the avatar sequels and be like
I'm going to try and beat that again so
obviously the line is going to keep pushing
forward but the thing that Joe Rogan
also addresses when he's talking to
Robert Downey jr. about Iron Man coming
back is that they tried these movies
without him and he suggests that maybe
they don't please the fans as much it
just doesn't go nearly as well for
Marvel as they would want and that
creates a real desire from a financial
standpoint to try and find a way to
include him in another Avengers movie
bring him back somehow like is there a
way we can do this without it sucking
and being a total cash grab because
movies are made to please fans but
mostly Studios make movies to earn money
so number four when Joe Rogan is
pitching Robert Downey jr. his idea for
bringing him back his second big go-to
is time-travel he says they have
time-travel now and after an Avengers
movie with you doesn't do well they grab
a version of Iron Man from a different
point in the timeline he steps out of
the time machine to a big reveal and
everyone in the theater flips out I do
totally buy that reaction as long as he
didn't come back in Doctor Strange 2
multiverse of madness which is the next
huge crossover mini Avengers movie
Captain America Civil War style because
it's got Scarlet Witch and Doctor
Strange ripping the multiverse wide open
but the story Joe Rogan is inadvertently
referring to when he's trying to pitch
this time-travel idea maybe without
realizing it is Young Avengers young
Avengers is mostly known for being a
time travel heavy franchise came to
conquer one of the most famous Young
Avengers villains also one of the most
famous Avengers level time-travel
villains that Marvel has not used yet I
love you as Iron Man so I would I would
if you if they opened up this time
machine and you popped out I just
imagine the moment where everybody goes
in crazy it would be amazing
it'd be great so number three Marvel
and Kevin Feige have spoken publicly
have they been considering a Young
Avengers movie or a Disney Plus series
for a long time now just a question of
setting the table in terms of
introducing the characters in the story
concepts that you would need for that
movie time-travel is a really good
example you have to introduce concepts
in the MCU before you do big movie based
on that concept like they introduce the
concept of the multiverse in the first
Doctor Strange movie then they
introduced the quantum realm in the
first two ant-man movies then during
Avengers endgame they combine those two
concepts and lean on them really heavy
to create their solution for saving the
universe now that they've introduced
time-travel to the MCU they can use it
as a story device in a much bigger way
in a new movie
young Avengers is just the perfect movie
for that they've even almost introduced
half of the original comic book young
Avengers team or will by the end of
Marvel phase 4 you have teenage Cassie
Lang aka stature she's the same basic
powers as ant-man in the wasp
there's the iron lad character last seen
during Iron Man's funeral at the end of
Avengers endgame she-hulk is going to debut
during the Marvel phase for she-hulk
series if they're not going to do the whole
Kling character I've also heard rumors
about him but we know that they're doing
she-hulk there's the cape bishop hawkeye
that's debuting during the Hawkeye
series and then Wiccan in speed that
seem like they're coming
during the Scarlet Witch Wanda vision
series there's still a couple years to
decide which characters they want to
include but there were six original
Avengers on the first team I think there
should be six members on the first
version of The Young Avengers team just
for that nice symmetry and if Robert
Downey jr. really Watts Joe Rogan to
participate like if I'm doing it you're
coming with me you can give him a cameo
as himself like Joe Rogan just passing
by them on the street
number two the next big solution for
bringing Iron Man back without
completely undermining his sacrifice
would be to have a major Marvel villain
try to steal his legacy in a much bigger
more literal way than Mysterio did think
about what Norman Osborn did in the
comics after Civil War in the events of
Dark Reign the Dark Avengers twisting
the legacy of Iron Man in a way that's
cool but also feels so wrong that you
want something to happen to bring them
down there's a cool twist on bringing
Iron Man back just to slap Norman Osborn
around you could totally do that without
having to bring Tony Stark back from the
dead you can do it with an artificial
consciousness of Iron Man in the comics
he's backed up his consciousness many
many
times they kind of iced his body after
Civil War - for a hot minute you had a
Jarvis version of Iron Man wisecracking
his way through the comics helping out
the heroes assessing the villains even
though I wasn't a huge fan of that comic
book run in general I know you were all
keen to have Doctor Doom show up in the MCU
that time when Ironman became an
artificial intelligence the person that
came to try and literally steal his
legacy was Doctor Doom but the big twist
with that event in the comics is that it
was Doctor Doom trying to be a hero
not like Norman Osborn iron patriot
during the Dark Avengers we've seen
rumors that Doctor Doom is going to be the
villain a black panther - I don't know
if those rumors are true so if they're
not going to go straight for Norman Osborn
in the sinister six movie Doctor Doom would
be the next option for that but here's
the big thing though number one it
seems very obvious that the sinister six
is being teased in the Morbius trailer
and all the spider-man crossover stuff
the Sony Marvel are cooking up with the
vulture showing up at the end of the
Morbius movie after watching that scene
it really does feel like a sinister six
movie is happening within the next
couple of years after spider-man 3 at
some point so it would be stupid to not
introduce an MCU version of Norman
Osborn at some point to be the man
pulling all the strings longtime comic
book sinister six fans will remember
that Doctor Octopus created the first
sinister six team but there's still a
mysterious quote-unquote benefactor
villain in the MCU the sunny birch was
working for during ant-man in the wasp
they had billions of dollars to throw
away and they didn't take no for an
answer there are only a couple of
characters in the comics that are
capable of doing something like that and
we know sinister 6 is happening at some
point it just makes sense that that
person in the MCU would be Norman Osborn
let me know in the comments though based
on what Joe Rogan is pitching for
bringing Iron Man back if it does go
down that way what would you want that
to look like bringing him back using a
time-travel twist how would they do that
without undermining his sacrifice during
avengers endgame and I got to go have
dinner with a bunch of the Marvel folks
last night and kinda have just a little
bit of extra closure because you know
the movie came out and it you know was
bananas and the directors are sending me
pictures of like people flipping out in
theatres is when Tony snaps and I was
like whoa this is kind of like a really
big cultural thing but then like
Victoria Alonso who's the head of VFX
are all these movies a literal super
genius or Kevin Feige or Favreau or
Scarlett or some people that I've just
have been there with it for a long time
we we we were there experiencing it all
when it came out and then we see each
other on a red carpet and it's not
intimate and then we kind of hadn't
really had a chance just to do nothing
just hang out and you know have some
crudité and kind of talk it was a
bunch of big Marvel phase four movie
announcements this past week I'll try to
do videos for a lot of that stuff as
soon as possible leave all your requests
in the comments below
so everyone click here for my brand new
Avengers evil Captain America a teaser
video and click here for my new Doctor
Strange two x-men video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight!